في المقدمه عددنا الكثير من الدول التي
يعني تعاني من ازمات حقيقه حقيقه ولا ندري
ان كان بعد ساعه او ساعتين يمكن ان يكون
هناك ازمه جديده على مستوى العالم حضرتك
ذكرت الصومال تحديدا هل يمكن ان نعتبر نصف
المال هي الدوله الاكثر الحاح عن الان
ضروره يجب ان يكون هناك يتحرك للمساعده
الصومال اكثر من غيرهم من الدول
من خلال اكثر من
مجموعه كبيره من البيانات وتعتمد على
عمليه حسابيه ولكن من اجل فهمي ما يحدث
فهناك جمله من الاحصاءات التي
هناك 54
مليون شخص
مليون متحده
لذا اذا نظرتم الى هذه الاحصائيات من
المؤكده النص الصراع صراع الجوع في شرق
افريقيا وهي تشمل الصومال واثيوبيا وكينيا
وعدد دول الثلاثه في افريقيا او في القرن
الافريقي فهي سوف هذه الدول المرشحه لترشح
لا وعلينا ان نتذكر ايضا
سوريا المكان